hello everyone we are still here at the
supper suite at South by Southwest and I
am so excited that blue moon is helping
us out this time because it means that
we get to cover movies like body upright
and rock and right now I have the
director here Roxanne Benjamin thank you
so much for coming by today yeah thanks
for having me I have so many questions
for you that hopefully I get to most of
them but one of the things that I
remember reading when you were promoting
xx was that you had a bunch of feature
projects kind of in the works and yeah
we're looking for financing so one what
was that process like for you and two
what was it like when you found out this
one got the go-ahead well I hadn't
written this one yet yeah at the time
when I was at Sundance with xx I had
another movie that I had written that
was a kind of bigger budget more grand
scale feature and I spent like a year
trying to get that together and the
financing kind of fell through at the
last second and I've made a movie every
year since producing the first VHS movie
in like 2010 so I was kind of losing my
mind a little bit so I I wrote this I
sat down and wrote this like the week I
find out I found out that our financing
had fallen through on the other movie
the bigger movie and went to my
post-production house the producers I
had worked with before a soap box Dave
Smith and Chris Allender and presented
it to them as this very low-budget movie
with just like one girl it's like a
chamber piece you know she's all by
herself it's her and you know this this
body that she finds and it'll be like no
big deal at all a very low budget and
they're like great let's do it finished
writing the script and then I took it
over to Magnolia and pre sold it to them
and then was like oh wait I just wrote a
movie about a girl in the middle of the
wilderness on the side of a mountain in
winter with lots of very messed up
things happening in the elements as my
like small movie to make before the
bigger movie and it's sounds like a
simple premise and simple concept and
like you're dealing with like one person
but there's so much that happens it's
actually way bigger than it sounds like
on paper I have a million production
questions as well but just cuz I think
it's always beneficial for people to
hear things like this what do you do
when you run into failure like that
because I just love hearing people's
stories about having a problem and then
overcoming it and especially when we're
talking about making a feature film
which is in my opinion next to
impossible and quite the achievement
with yeah it's like not until you make
any sort of film on your own that you
start to really respect every other
movie that you may have taken like for
granted or if it had some sort of flaw
however small and you were like me that
wasn't as like good as I expect you're
like every movie is a miracle
of any kind that it comes together and
actually gets made and yeah it's funny
how you put that because like someone
overcoming failure is actually what the
movie is really about is someone
overcoming like their own sense of
failure through a series of being tested
in ways that like they didn't know that
they could be tested and would come out
more on the positive side or for better
or worse through the experience however
bad it might be and when it comes to
like production every kind of failure is
a new opportunity to find something in
the movie that you didn't know needed to
be there is really the way I look at it
absolutely what was it about the park
ranger lost in the woods scenario that
really spoke to you especially given the
fact that like you wrote this so quickly
to you how did that come to mind well I
was working in a park and a lot of the
people who worked our or just like
part-time students you know it's like
there's summer job kind of thing and I
spent a lot of time in like the national
parks with my dad we go camping a lot we
go hiking a lot like every year to all
the national parks we usually hit like
one a year for like a couple days or a
week and it's very easy to get out in
the wilderness and you have no cell
reception and like there's a real reason
like in a horror movie for there
actually to be no cell reception and
things can go from like oh we're just
having pleasant day
- dire very quickly I also grew up in
rural Pennsylvania in the woods so
that's kind of more what I'm used to and
like it's more like home to me which is
why most of the things that I write take
place outside in nature especially when
you're dealing with low budget and you
don't have a lot of money to put into
like production value letting nature be
your production design along with I mean
I have amazing production designers the
andujar twins who worked on this movie
but letting kind of nature be the
palette that sets the tone of the movie
is something that I try to work into
almost everything I do given your
experience in this realm have you ever
gone through something that obviously
isn't exactly like what we see in the
movie but anything kind of frightening
at all that you were able to work into
this character um
I've definitely gotten lost in the woods
before and it takes like a very short
amount of time before you're like this
is my life now I'm gonna have to learn
how to like skin animals and eat them
and like I'm gonna just you know have to
like build a lean-to and try to remember
like Girl Scout knowledge that like you
know we we weren't like Boy Scouts and
Girl Scouts when I was a kid we're very
separate like the Boy Scouts got to
learn like how to build fires and like
you know like trap things and like we
were learning how to like sew buttons
onto stuff from what I remember you know
but this is like a long long time ago
I'm sure it's much more diverse now but
yeah it's it's definitely a situation
I've been in or even just camping alone
at night where every little bump you're
convinced is like either someone coming
to kill you or like something in nature
that is coming to kill you so it's
either someone or something really I
should not be alone in the woods at all
given like my amount of paranoia but
like since that's how I grew up like
these were the kind of fears that I know
how to present
I guess not experienced in camping but I
feel like my mind automatically goes
there because I've been watched just too
many horror movies since I was like yeah
any trial yeah
exactly and then it gets all preparing
me though I'm maybe I'm better off for
it yeah it was also like with this movie
I feel like we all like it's funny
because I've asked people in like
audiences or even just
when they've seen the movie like if they
had read a book in junior high called
hatchet which oh my god right I did read
that book I don't know why all of us
read this book like everyone had to read
this book for some reason and it was
about this boy who was like you know his
plane went down and guys like daddy
issues and there's like he's left with
just this like one tool that he has to
like get out of the wilderness and like
find himself not thought about right
books since probably what I'm really in
a formative age like we all read this
book in that kind of book or like the
Jack London books you know which we're
always very like rugged man versus
nature kind of things and like finding
yourself in nature but I feel like there
were not a lot of female character
driven stories like that and I wanted
there to be so this is kind of my
version of that it's like a mix of that
and like I read a lot of like
Christopher Pike as like a you know
young kid at a much too early age
probably sits it's I was trying to make
something that was much more almost like
young adult horror fiction or young
adult psychological thriller than an
actual adults horror movie I needed more
of that as a kid yeah right I was going
for straight the adult super hard are
yeah here we are today yep and here we
are I wanted to know about making this
specific character too because one of
the things that I appreciated about her
most is like she felt very very much
like obviously she doesn't really know
what she's doing she shouldn't be on
that trail but also she's someone who
constantly makes mistakes for a good
degree of the movie yeah I don't know I
thought that was like a very bold choice
because oftentimes we see something like
this and so soon into the movie you're
given confidence like no they can do it
it'll yeah okay and you don't really do
that and I think it keeps you on edge a
little more yeah it's like a it's a
delicate balance because I didn't want
Wendy to seem like completely
incompetent the idea is that like she's
figuring out that she can do these thing
it's like someone who doesn't have
confidence in themselves realizing that
they they can actually survive something
which I feel like is a very univille
universal story that people should tell
it's like making movies I can't even
begin to tell you how many times I've
had the conversation of should I go
film school or should I just get out
there and learn and sometimes you're
fumbling around round one but yeah help
you learn and it's also if that was a
real person in this scenario they're not
gonna instantly turn into like you know
Little Miss wilderness you know and
again it's like a lot of people who kind
of work in these part-time jobs for the
summer it's like you don't have like
you're not like wilderness trained you
know like it's not expected that you're
you're gonna get stuck somewhere for
like a night or two nights it's like
you're gonna be on a trail for a couple
hours like things should be fine but
it's kind of this razor-thin edge I
think we all walk on that like things
could Teeter into calamity so much more
quickly than we kind of walk around
thinking that they could and that's kind
of what I wanted to explore like what
happens when everything goes wrong and
some of it's her fault and some of it
isn't and then it becomes a little bit
of a comedy of errors and I don't know
how to make things without some sort of
comedic tone to them so I wanted her to
kind of be in on that rather than like
the butt of that have you thought much
because I I'm sure you love all horror
movies like I do and one of the things
that it gets me thinking about all the
time is like what I would do in the face
of like an emergency in a split second
like that so like whether it's camping
or all of a sudden turning around and
seeing a slasher behind you have you
ever tried to process like would I be
okay in the situation I I don't know
it's like when you work in this genre
it's what you think about in every
scenario like there's always someone
under the bed there's always someone
behind the shower curtain like you can't
close a mirror on a cabinet ever like
you have to turn around and look first
so we're probably Buber prepared or were
just like in a constant state of
fight-or-flight one of the other okay
yeah it's like a pretty accurate
assessment right there yeah going back
to the tone I was wondering how you
figure out that balance here because I
mean there it almost also has like a
little bit of a western tone to it also
did you have that set right from the
start oh yeah figuring out yeah no that
was definitely part of the tone the
whole way through
I wanted this very like 70s
girl out on her own against the elements
going on this journey and the kind of
Western thriller vibe but set in the
woods was something that I hadn't really
seen before and the whole color palette
was designed around that the fact that
there's like an opening coda was
designed around that and my composers
the gifted are amazing I've worked with
them on a couple of different projects
now they did my southbound score and my
xx score so they're really great at like
being able to meld these different tones
together and we took a lot of time
figuring out like what those themes
would be and where we would marry them
and and just giving it this kind of very
I don't want to say vintagey or
nostalgic tone but I it's like I was
trying to make a 70s TV movie that
didn't exist that I wish I had seen in
my childhood I could see that touch yeah
speaking of XX southbound you've also
had more producing experience beyond
that but this is your first feature as a
director so even with all that
experience was there anything with
making the making of this movie that
made you think like how did I not know
that before not really honestly because
I had worked on so many features with so
many different directors at that point
that there wasn't anything that was so
much of a surprise as it was just I wish
we had more time which i think is what
everyone thinks but you know we had
eleven days to shoot the movie up on the
side of a mountain and winter by and
there was a windstorm up in Idlewild
where we shot that like they invented a
new category of storm for that shut down
the power in the town for two entire
days so we couldn't shoot and like
couldn't run generators trees were
coming down like it was bad so we ended
up shooting for like nine and a half
days and then plus an extra day two
months later that was already planned
ahead of time that would be a big
spoiler if I talked about but has to do
with the ending the movie there was like
pre planned to be a later date so we
ended up like just having like an eleven
a half day eleven and a half days shoot
I think by the end of it over the course
of like three months so just having more
time I think would have been the one
major thing
you know I made this movie for less than
the first VHS movie which was a found
footage movie made in 2010 and that's
kind of like what I could the financing
that I could get so yeah so impressive
that you pulled it off how long were
those days for nine and a half days well
they're only like production days are
typically twelve hour days so we were
never really going over our production
schedule but they definitely felt longer
because we were hiking the whole time -
we were hiking up and down the side of
the I mean I say mountain it is an
actual mountain but we were in like a
park a state park up in Idlewild and
California which is about like 6500 or
7,000 feet above sea level between Los
Angeles and Palm Springs
it's very lit very much like Big Bear
California it's the small like mountain
town there's nothing but there's like
one Road in and out so we were having to
hike up and down like the side of the
trails every day and then you know it's
also like we're in the dark on the side
of the mountain too so there's like a
lot of safety stuff that you have to
deal with it was like a big part of
planning the shoot as well is there
anything super like that might look
super simple to a viewer watching her
climb some sort of rock face that
actually came with a lot more
complications than anyone would imagine
um mostly I would say it was just the
night stuff mm-hmm
because putting the night stuff together
when you know you're on you're in the
clearing on the side of a mountain you
have to get your lights up higher and
the winds were so crazy it was like
tying down our lights was one of the
harder things that and hoisting my DP up
into a tree yep we tied her literally
tied her to a tree tree branch left her
up there but also Casey Adams who's also
in the film he's a stunt coordinator and
stunt man so I cast him a lot of things
and he is very knowledgeable about like
what can can't be done and we have other
stunt coordinators involved in the film
as well that are friends friends of his
but one of the reasons I like casting
him besides the fact that I think that
he's a
good actor is that he's very aware of
how to do a lot of things like that in a
safe way and to help other people kind
of feel comfortable doing those things
mostly climbing on the rocks was like
more treacherous for like us like as the
crew I think than the cast because like
they were very we had them placed very
carefully but the rest of us had to like
get those shots around them and there
are a lot of shots up there that are
like kind of on the precipice no this is
a quick and easy film for us in one
location
mostly daytime like easy peasy no big
deal yeah I feel like that's how all
those conversations began yeah so given
your experience on this now eh where is
your mind that just in terms of future
projects are you basically back in
another situation where you've got a
whole bunch of other things out there
and cooking and you're kind of waiting
for something to go yeah that's
basically I mean that's the name of the
game like every time and you just start
over from scratch and hope that you can
get a little bit bigger budget every
time it's it's weird to think that this
is my first feature because it feels
like I've been directing for so long
yeah but I forget that that you know
it's just like pieces of anthologies
that I've directed mm-hmm I just
finished writing a script for Orion the
remake of Knight of the con yes so
that's done so now I'm just looking for
new projects I feel like the tone of
that seems so much more perfect for you
now that I've seen this makes a little
more today aligned at all just in terms
of the style I'm I really like writing
stories about female relationships and
female dynamics in terms of friendships
because I find them fascinating and I
feel like it's something that I want to
see explored more for characters that
are of a younger age comedy I feel like
there's a lot more like straight comedy
stuff that that is geared towards like
late 20s early 30s maybe you don't see
it as much in like teen age or like more
like why a that deals with like real
life things well also having
a comedic tone to it or comedic
undertones so that's kind of where I
feel like that's my that's my lane okay
I like the sound of that and is there
anything that you learned making this
movie that you're gonna take with you or
something that's kind of drilled in your
mind now there's I mean you learn so
many things on every single movie that
you make that you didn't know before and
it's it's weird like every person has a
completely unique experience when it
comes to how they make films are like
the knowledge that they have based on
the problems that you had to solve on
the prior film and for this one I
honestly think it's just dealing with
like a single character and how to build
a single character narrative Karina
fountas who's the star of the movie this
is her first feature she'd never she
never acted in a feature I don't know I
kind of like wiped that away because I
knew she was in South Bay yeah but she's
she's the band member and southbound in
my section that no longer exists that
she's the one that's missing that
they're all talking about all the time
and then she shows up in like the
nightmares and stuff but she doesn't
have any lines she's not like a real
character in the film's images she's a
presence yeah film so this is her first
this is like her debut acting role so I
was also working with like a first-time
actor and not in that capacity and she
carries the film you know the film is
based around her really threw her in the
deep end yeah I was like here you go
we're both just gonna like dive in here
I'm sure it'll be great yeah one more
thing I want to ask you about is just
the idea of ladies in horror because
obviously I'm like a hard nut in the
community is very important to me and
ever since you started working on you
know the VHS films your name has been a
major one in that community so where do
you see kind of like ladies and horror
going right now I know it's a very broad
question but I just kind of like
highlighting any any like bright
potential future this is genre and
specifically female from filmmakers have
in it
I hope to see more opportunities for all
independent filmmakers I think I feel
like there's a lot more
directing opportunities then there used
to be potentially like you always I
always think of like the the people that
I liked when I was kind of coming up who
were more in the produce Oriole side of
things and it feels like there's
definitely more more women taking the
step into directing and it feels like
it's more accessible now to everyone
which I think you can't really go wrong
with with that absolutely is there
anything happening in the genre this
year that's really exciting you a movie
you're looking forward to something that
you just saw that really made a big
impression it's well definitely enough I
haven't seen anything for a while
because I've been making this you're
kind of in a rabbit hole when you're a
movie and finishing a movie where you're
just like I looked up and I was like oh
the Oscars are happening and like had
completely forgotten so there hasn't
been anything that's really been on my
radar so much as I'm very excited about
Pet Sematary genesis of IV as Amon and
us Jordan peels new movie I was trying
to figure out like can I skip my own
like pre premiere party to go see us
like I can't do that can't I but it was
the only time it was playing so at least
it's well worth the wait I was like they
would understand they would understand
so yeah I'm definitely excited to see
those good stuff well thank you so much
for coming by today to talk body at
Brighton Rock keep an eye out for it
Roxane thank you again hope you have a
great south-by-southwest
guys we we will be back at the supper
suite real soon with more interviews
you